feels like nobody else on board
understand or can understand or cares
should I feeling just a light completely
Alejo
Gaynor Spence hasn't lived through
lockdown she survived it
isolation made her existing depression
so bad a few weeks ago she planned to
kill herself
it grows worse because you don't tell
anybody and you don't speak to anybody
at first so we got that's how it grows
into them feelings of one's gonna miss
you and no one no one would even know
you feel like that like no one would
even know if you were gone
and and it would just stop the pain a
feeling so down and so alone and if
progress is on to them feelings of
there's no point in being here Gaynor
was able to get help so when you say
you're you're feeling down and whilst
there is still no hard data on how
lockdown has affected suicide rates
calls to this suicide prevention charity
have tripled we were already in a
complete crisis before coab had happened
and you know services are so so
stretched and unable to keep up with the
demand and waiting lists are so high
hence why a service like ours is needed
and I'm very concerned about what
happens during coronavirus and following
coronavirus when that demand is only
going to go up and up and up for a
significant period of time mental health
services say they need more funding the
government knows it's an issue with
public health campaigns to reach the
vulnerable already underway prone to
exist but the future does look worrying
especially in areas like that pool which
will be hard hit by this pandemics ikan
in the 2008 financial crisis we showed
that that led to about a thousand more
suicides in England than would have been
expected and it was particularly those
areas that were worst hit by increases
in unemployment but those things are not
inevitable the mental health effects of
recession tend to be less severe in
those countries that have invested more
in supporting people when they're out of
work that means a combination of welfare
and mental health support and when there
is help there is hope I know at the time
you feel you just want to sit there and
you don't want to tell anybody how
you're feeling but don't don't think you
alone just reach out and don't feel
ashamed even if you reaching out to a
stranger
katarina vertice Sky News